what's going on everyone my name is alex
ramose i'm the ceo and founder of allen
prestige labs gym lunch and we own a
portfolio of other companies who've done
120 plus million in the last four years
and i have nothing to sell you in this
video what i want to do is show you
the eight principles charlie munger
taught me to succeed in business and
life and
uh by no means by saying that i have
completely executed all these things in
my life these are just aspirational
things that
i think benefit most humans those of you
who know me
i'm a huge a huge fan i've consumed a
lot
of his materials and so i wanted to
consolidate his speeches
and his his work into
these principles for anyone who's kind
of new to charlie munger
and so i'm not going to do these in
order i'm going to do these in the order
i think it makes the most sense to
present them the first one
is invert always invert and so he
references johnny carson in one of his
speeches to always try and solve
problems in reverse
and this has been something that's been
immensely powerful i think because for
us
using thinking frameworks in order to
make decisions in order to solve
problems as both you know entrepreneurs
business people
and then just just in daily life so many
times we try and
solve it logically going forward towards
it and it gives you this entirely fresh
perspective
to start at what you don't want and then
try and solve
from that direction and that'll kind of
lead way into
the other eight excuse me the other
seven
of the lessons and at the very end i'll
give you the one the one thing that i
if just from the the things that we've
done that i would add
uh to the list that has been really
helpful for us or rather
things to avoid so his first thing that
you hear him talk about all the time is
just
don't ingest chemicals to alter your
state right he's like i've never heard
of someone like if i wanted to be really
poor or really
unsuccessful in life what would i do
he's like well i would definitely get
addicted to chemicals
right and so this sounds so logical like
obvious to us but in
instead so many of us uh still use that
stuff on a regular basis to alter our
mood because we can't cope with
some of the issues that are coming up in
our lives he's like i can't imagine
anyone who's thought to themselves man
my life is so much better
now that i because i because i do drugs
and because i i drink
and i'm not saying that you know that's
a judgment in any way it's just
one of the principles that he's found to
be a successful trait for himself and
others
number three envy so one of the things
that's been a gift for warren buffett
and charlie munger together
is this statement that they made both of
them being you know super billionaires
and they said every single year someone
is doing better than us
and for me that was so like like uh
gut wrenching's the wrong word but like
that hit me because i think
i am so i am innately so competitive
that i suffer
from comparison all the time i was
actually texting a friend this morning
who's also a you know
multi-leader deck of billionaire and he
was saying
he's like i feel like the more money i
make the poorer i feel and
it's totally true because what ends up
happening is that your your measuring
stick changes i remember
you know when i when i was really really
young my measuring stick for money was
chipotle burritos
it was just how many chipotle burritos
does this amount of money equate to and
so
i actually think that we have like a
stick or a unit that becomes our base
unit
when we're measuring wealth for
ourselves and that's why when i think i
had a hundred thousand dollars in my
bank account
that was probably the wealthiest i have
ever felt because i had
proportional to what my measuring stick
was which at that time was still meals
a hundred thousand dollars was so much
so much money so many
of those units at this point in my life
a million dollars is kind of my
measuring unit
that i use as a base unit for how many
how many of these do i have in this how
many
how many you know how many sticks do i
have in you know real estate how many
sticks i have in
in in my portfolio how much do i have in
equity in these companies etc
and so that stick changes but someone is
always doing better
but i think it's so much more about not
thinking about them because
the way that they roll the dice and play
the game has no effect on us and so
simply it's an imaginary
way to make yourself suffer so if you
want to suffer definitely
be envious of people the fourth one was
definitely resent people like really
hold on to resentment if you want to be
miserable
and so one of the stories that charlie
tells us of a king
who committing trying to not be
resentful of people what he would do is
every time he'd want to resent someone
he'd write their name down
and he'd put it on a slip of paper in a
drawer and periodically he'd go to that
drawer
open it up and read the names and
realize how life had dealt with those
people without him having to do anything
and so i think it's one of those
long-term mindedness that like
most people live in karmic balance
independent of whether or not you
believe in you know that kind of woo
stuff but simply like people who do bad
things
eventually that catches up to them and
it is worse for them
and so you like someone who exists in
that state is already dealing with the
suffering of being who they are
and so you know if you want to be
miserable definitely resent people
the next one is uh be unreliable right
like if you want to
definitely be miserable like be
unreliable say you're going to do
something and don't do it say you're
going to be somewhere and
and be late be flaky make commitments
that you don't keep
and this one is one of those ones that
he references a lot of times as
he's like if you just get this one right
and you are reliable it's very difficult
to be miserable it's very difficult to
be unsuccessful
and there was a guy that i was that i
knew in high school
and this is when i had a you know a
bigger ego than i have now
and i was such a so i was such a dick i
honestly i was just there's no other way
to say it i just was
and this kid was just like
he stayed he went to all the extra
credit for for teachers
he worked so hard and he had nothing
going for him like he wasn't
like the best looking kid he wasn't
athletic like he didn't have like this
natural processing power he wasn't quick
like that
but i remember and i was such a mean guy
to this kid and i remember one time
he we got in some sort of spat and i was
like in what world will you ever be
better than me at anything
and i remember saying that you can you
can feel it's so dripped in ego and it's
just kind of disgusting but
anyways i said this to him and he ended
up getting into a better college than me
i ended up going to vanderbilt he ended
up going to duke
and i just remembered that moment
because it was such a deep lesson for me
that like
he was more reliable than i was he was
more long-suffering than i was he was
more consistent than i was he showed up
to every
teacher's thing he showed up he did all
the extra credit he did all the homework
he
he like he did all those things and he
just showed up
and that was a huge lesson for me that i
was like if i can just show up like that
guy does like man
things will open up for me but if you
want to fail definitely be unreliable
the next one is overspend your income
you know definitely if you want to get
if you want to if you want to put
yourself in a horrible situation on a
regular basis and consistently have
stress
definitely spend more than you make
which you know america is doing
right now with their own gdp but we
won't even get into that but definitely
overspend what you make like don't save
you know spend more than what you have
always have bigger aspirations than you
have the ability to fulfill on
and definitely always live in debt and
the wrong kind of debt the bad debt
and so if you've any followed any of my
stuff my
my i'm a huge proponent of living broke
all the time
and it's because i believe wealth is a
ratio between
income and expenses it's not a number
right if you can live on one percent of
what you make
as a hypothetical example then you are
in you were infinitely wealthy because
you already have a hundred times more
your income is a hundred times more than
your expenses which means you could live
veritably for 100 years
and so just on one year's income so
that's an extreme example just to
illustrate the point
but if you like for me i feel less and
less anxiety
the the greater the percentages of
excess i have in my expenditures versus
how i live
and so there's two ways to get there one
is you can increase how much you make
the other ways you can decrease how much
you spend
but the thing is is no matter where you
are right now the one that you can
immediately change
is how much you spend over time you can
use those that those extra funds invest
in yourself
grow the top line so that you can even
make that discrepancy crazier
so that your wealth can increase that
ratio being your wealth
can increase and so for me i try and
live on ten percent that that hundred
thousand dollar story
that i gave you earlier once i was i had
a million dollars in my bank account
i still lived on thirty thousand dollars
a year and so i was
you know i was living on three percent
um at that point of my wealth but my
income was
was already surpassing a million dollars
a year at that point
and so i was living on three percent of
what i was taking home
and honestly i felt so free because i
just knew that i had way more money than
i would ever need
that's very freeing so but if you want
to fail definitely overspend your income
the next one is learn only from your own
mistakes right don't learn from the
mistakes of others don't learn from
other people's successes
and what i want to add as a wrinkle to
this is that
depending on where you're at in your
journey this is something that i've
observed is
um you in the very very beginning you
have no value to offer i get messages
frequently of people being like hey uh
let's start a business together i'll
give you half and i'm like well you're
providing no value i'm the one who would
know how to run this business so this is
not a good trade for me
you know return on my time is not very
good another one is i i'll work with you
you know i'll work for you for free
you know if you teach me everything and
i was like yeah that's so i'm getting
someone who has no skills and no value
and exchange you're getting an education
from someone you know like that's not a
fair that's not a good exchange for me
right
and so what you have to do is find ways
where even that
you can trade your base level which is
time
for someone who has a need for that
level of skill who's ahead of you
and that's where like small businesses
like if someone's making a hundred
thousand
a year or two hundred thousand dollars a
year in a business that's not a very big
business
but if you if you say i will work for
free for you
then someone like that can still use for
lack of a better term
just hands right someone who can just
help and just be there as a body
and i know that may sound diminutive
towards you but if you have no base
skills
that is that is your base skill that you
have is you have your time in your hands
right and so you use that and then you
can learn some more skills and then from
that point
you develop the next level which is
where you can start affording coaches
right uh from the level above that when
i say learning only from your own
mistakes first is you learn from
people for free by exchanging your time
then you learn from coaches
then you can learn from masterminds
which is people where you are now
at this point equal with other people in
the room who are good
and what i will tell you is this if
you're at eight figures i'm switching
gears in terms of who i'm talking to
but as you go up this journey how you
network and learn from others
changes it evolves and you know i i went
the
coach route for the first you know three
four years of my
entrepreneurial journey and then it was
much more towards the mastermind route
uh later on but the thing is is once we
pass eight figures
for us in terms of yearly revenue and
yearly income
it's shifted to being much more about
networking and advisors
so that's kind of two different things
networking is like other people who are
at that level
that you just network with and you meet
at things and you donate to same
charities that kind of thing
and the other aspect is like well if you
want someone ahead of you at that point
it a lot of times a you can still get it
from the network sometimes but
if you really want to get a lot from
someone you need to make sure that
there's some sort of exchange that's
fair
and that's where kind of advisory
relationships work really well and so i
have an advisor
and that means that you know they get a
minority percentage and something that
you guys are working on
and so they have an incentive to teach
you some of these elements and you
at this point you're already proven as
an effective person you have the
character traits of
being reliable you know not being
envious having lung suffering having the
abilities to execute
so they know that they can just drop the
information in and then it will be
incorporated and then they can succeed
with you
and then the final aspect is what i
would say the highest level is heroes
because a lot of people we don't have
access to you know what i mean even this
video right now like i don't know
charlie munger i have not met charlie
munger but charlie munger is a hero of
mine
and so i feel like i've been directly
mentored by
charlie despite the fact that i've never
met the man and so i'm eternally
grateful for man because he's
you know significantly changed my life
for the better which
will naturally lead me to the his last
point and then i'll give you
the one that i would add um just from my
own experience in my life
so his last point would be quit when you
have your third or fourth big failure in
life
he said so if you want to if you want to
fail and you want to be miserable you
should definitely quit
soon quit early right he's like because
no matter who you are you're going to
fail
not just once or twice or three times or
four times but you will fail many times
and if you if you quit early then you
can guarantee that you will be you know
miserable for a very long time
after that because then you have given
up hope and you'll have nothing to
strive towards you'll have no purpose
and so if you want to be miserable
definitely quit early right and even
count the amount of times you failed
because
because for some reason that means
something right it doesn't mean anything
and so to wrap this up i'll give you
alex's one
that's been tremendously helpful for me
which is
this is kind of started from a speech i
heard one of the presidents say
from the past but was the the way to
be successful is to be able to handle
pressure
right so if you want to if you want to
if you want to fail
definitely crack under pressure like no
matter what happens just crack
under pressure crack when people need
you and so
my my candid solution for this are the
things that have helped me
is understanding a what it is which is
most of us just create arbitrary
expectations
and then crumble under pressures that we
put on ourselves that don't actually
exist in the world
we literally create things to weigh
ourselves down which
i feel like the further along you get
into the entrepreneurial game it becomes
headier and headier
because you realize it's so much just
about the limits that you place on
yourself
and so here's three strategies that i
have used that are mentally
have that have mentally made me much
more resilient the first and i got this
from from trevor who got it from
epictetus which is
aged philosopher is negative
visualization and so let me give you a
tactical example of that
this is a simple example so i just spent
a couple hundred dollars on a shirt and
i really like the shirt and i don't
really spend money a lot on on clothing
um and after i wash the shirt it was
like messed up
i'll just put it simply right this is a
simple example to illustrate
and and then he had just taught me about
this negative visualization the day
before
and he said take something that happens
negative
and then imagine it happening a thousand
more times in a row
how would you feel in the thousandth
time and i thought to myself if every
time i washed a shirt you know it shrunk
like this
or something or it became rougher around
the edges and i got it because it was
soft
i probably wouldn't care that much it
would just be like ah that's just how
these things are
and so it means is that my expectations
would change in my mind to what they to
match reality and then at that point my
misery would disappear
and so that's literally what i did in
the moment and i felt myself just stop
caring about this thing that actually
bugged me a little bit because i was
like man that's annoying
but you can use that same concept with
any of the things that occur in your
life when it's like man my
my my wife said this thing well what if
she said that thing a thousand times in
a row you'd be like well i guess that's
just kind of how
how she is or that's just kind of how
things are and then all of a sudden
you would acclimate it but you can
rapidly force the acclimation to stress
by visualizing it happening thousands of
times and then skipping to the end
because if you can feel that way after a
thousand times then you might as well
feel that way after the first time
and that has been so powerful for me
because we have so many stressors that
come in our lives and we set
expectations that we're even
not aware that we're setting and then
get underperformed on the second
uh thing that's been really helpful for
me is that if i want to start a new
behavior
or i'm trying to do something that is
difficult then what i want to do is go
into it and expect the worst and let me
give you a real
that sounds obvious but let me give you
a realistic reasoning for this
so let's say that you want to start
working out
mentally prepare yourself for the fact
that every time i work out i'm going to
be tired
every time i work out i'm going to not
be motivated
and that's just going to be my base
reality if i happen to be motivated or i
happen to not be exhausted or i happen
to not have a lot of work to do
then then that's just a bonus it's
serendipitous
it's just a happy uh coincidence but i
expect that every time i work out i will
be tired i'll have more things to do
and i will not you know be motivated to
do so and if i come in with that
expectation and i set that as my
baseline
then i am not surprised when i go to
work out and i feel that way because
then
it is in alignment with the expectations
that i have in my mind
the third of the sub subtext of uh you
know creating false expectations
and crumbling under pressures that we
create for ourselves
is one that is will probably be
controversial for some of you
but this is a belief that i hold and it
has been immensely powerful for me in
terms of
increasing my joy in life which is elon
musk i heard him talk
a while back about how he said
eventually the universe
will expand infinitely until everything
becomes a fine mist
everything just becomes a fine mist if
you extend the time horizon long enough
and for me that means that everything
that we create
on earth and as humanity will eventually
disappear so the skyscrapers the books
that i write
the people that we help people who
remember us the legacy that we are
trying to have
after we die even that will eventually
turn into a fine mist
and not matter and for me
that is so immensely powerful because it
means
that nothing matters and at the same
time it means that we get to choose what
things we
we create meaning with and so i believe
our brains are simply meaning making
machines and i love that term so i'm
giving it to you
is that just i have this meaning making
machine in my mind which
everything has no meaning and then i can
choose to highlight
aspects that i i will create meaning for
and so understanding that the millions
that i have
maybe the billions that i'll make in my
lifetime and the wealth that i
accumulate the reputation
the books the impact all of that stuff
will eventually disappear
truly it will eventually be gone there
will be a day where no one knows that i
existed or anything like that
in some ways it frees me in the present
knowing that everything that i do
will eventually mean nothing and so all
of us are essentially in my mind
you know there's the the nazi
concentration camps uh people would dig
holes and then they'd fill holes back up
again
and it was it was basically meaningless
work but it was only meaningless because
they believed
that it was meaningless right but
essentially all of us in my own mind and
my understanding of reality
are simply just digging holes every day
that will eventually when the time
horizon is long enough
get filled back with dirt and so what
that means is
imagine i was in that same concentration
camp for example
which might be an analogy for life and
instead of being given a shovel to dig
holes they said you can do whatever you
want
but at the end of your life you have to
undo it all right
well then i could probably ha i could
probably engineer a fairly joyful
experience for myself because i would do
things that are stimulating for me
that i find enjoyable right and so
by doing that it just removed all of the
expectations and a lot of the envy
that i have for other people because i
know that all of us in the
end there's no box that we take with us
right and so
that's just been just wildly impactful
for me
as a human being and in terms of
decreasing pressure in my life
in business there's just nothing that's
that big of a deal
right because eventually all of it's
going to disappear anyways so if
someone's upset with you it's like well
you know we're all going to become a
fine mist in the future eventually
you know like ah you know we've got this
competitor who's who's
stealing our stuff you know we're all
going to disappear into a fine mist
eventually
and that has been so calming for me and
has relieved so much pressure
for me mentally that may be depressing
for some people for me it's wildly
freeing
and so um i guess if it's depressing for
you then don't think about it but if
if that resonates with you then then
maybe you can use that as a weapon in
your arsenal
to defend against the pressures that we
inevitably put on ourselves that we can
deconstruct and deflate
and so anyways those are the lessons
that i have learned from charlie munger
as my hero and mentor
uh from consuming so much of his content
i hope you found value in that
if you are you know if you're a business
owner i make a lot of more tactical
things
about how to make money and all that
stuff on this channel if you like this
stuff
click and subscribe otherwise hope you
enjoyed and i'll catch you on the next
video